the number one thing is mental toughness  and and i've just realized it's only  through taking action  it's only through like getting backed  into that corner and then having the  courage to take that next step saying  my leg might snap  but i am willing to take that next step  and you you cannot learn it by reading  it you cannot learn it by  hearing somebody those are all great  like sparks or motivation pieces to get  you going on your journey but ultimately  at the end of the day you've got to show  up you've got to participate you have to  learn and you can't  you can't go from zero to 100. everybody  can develop it because i'm a great  example of  this is a mental journey